[Applause]
[Music]
so as we continue with Infinity Gauntlet
issue number six what we're gonna see
here is this story beginning to come to
a close now that doesn't necessarily
mean that all the action and everything
is going to wind down in fact we're
gonna be covering a lot of ground in a
very short amount of time and so like
issue number five we're gonna be
splitting issue number six into two
parts but what we see as the store
begins to unfold are a couple things the
first is that nebula has imprisoned
Thanos in a structure of rock that he
can't escape from but the other thing
and the more important thing here is
that Doctor Strange and the Silver
Surfer are coming to realize something
that Adam warlock exists outside the
realms of chaos and order and in fact
may very well as exist outside of this
reality and Thanos vocalizes this
thought or at the very least he
interprets this thought for us and tells
us that nebula is completely unaware of
Adam warlocks presence she doesn't know
that he's there now the reason why in
terms of why
Thanos knew that Adam warlock was there
but why nebula doesn't know Adam warlock
is here is because Thanos more or less
tells for this
Thanos tells nebula that sure her
intellectual capacity is not up to task
for wielding the Infinity Gauntlet that
in fact she's not able to tap into its
full power and that if she was she would
have immediately known that Adam warlock
was there even if on some kind of
sensory level even if she couldn't
physically see him she would have been
able to read his thoughts or she would
have known what he was thinking now the
fact that nebula can't see Adam warlock
is an extremely important thing and this
will become a major issue later on
although it won't necessarily be in the
form that you think it is but what we
see is that Thanos again continues to
taunt nebula
he tells nebula that she doesn't have
the vision to properly exploit the
infinity gems and nebula asks him
whether or not he believes he does and
that oh says yes he says look at what it
was that he was able to accomplish so
far using the infinity gems now this is
really interesting when it comes to
nebula because nebula describes his
actions as killing off half the life in
the universe
in a very sarcastic way indicating to us
that this is something that she finds
appalling now whether or not this is
because nebula is trying to step into
the role of a good guy here
or because nebula is on the inside a
good guy instead of a villain is not
something that's explained to us but I
would go as far as to say that nebula
when you consider her previous actions
in the Marvel Comics especially when it
came to eliminating the Nova Corps is
not necessarily a good person but the
idea of eliminating half the life in the
universe is something that would be
considered incomprehensible to all but
the most extreme nihilist in the Marvel
Comics one of which is of course Thanos
and so what she says is that the R or
the reign of Thanos in the universe with
regards to his possession of the
Infinity Gauntlet is something that
cannot be allowed to stand and that
she's going to use the Infinity Gauntlet
to more or less set everything back to
rights but what we also see here is that
Adam warlock is signaling to dr. strange
silently and again this is Adam warlock
taking precautions to is to ensure that
nebula doesn't know that he's there and
so Doctor Strange uses his magic to do
something also at the moment we don't
know what that is
but what we see is that nebula uses the
Infinity Gauntlet to set everything back
to the way it was before
now with the things that are coming up
with the things that are going to be
taking place I'm curious to see whether
or not you would be able to predict them
because what we're going to be seeing is
that things are going to be changing in
such a way that's some very interesting
circumstances are going to arise but
what we see is that as a result of
nebula setting everything back to the
way it was before that of course half
the life in the universe is destroyed
I'm sorry is not restored but with
everything being restored to 24 hours
prior nebula s 1006 planes it to us
reverts back into the previous form that
she had when she was a husk of a being
and so Thanos again allows his arrogance
to I get the better of him as he begins
to brag as he begins to more or less
taut nebula and say that when she has
the power of godhood she should be
careful because whatever is whatever it
is that she wishes for will come true
and so she has to exercise some measure
of forethought but before that is able
to seize the Infinity Gauntlet from her
nebula restores herself back to the way
she was before and again what she does
is she allows her arrogance to get the
better of her and she begins to taunt
Thanos and re imprison Thanos and saying
that the mistake that he made was
allowing himself to be arrogant was
allowing himself to believe that because
she had been referred back to her former
form that she would not be able to
revert herself back or I guess restore
herself back to normal but what we also
see is that Adam warlock appears to be
reaching for the Infinity Gauntlet now
what it is that he intends to do here is
something we're not entirely sure of
although we're more or less led to
believe that maybe he's going to take
this chance while she's talking just
strip her of the Infinity Gauntlet but
what what Adam warlock does here is it
seems as though he touches the intro
Finity gauntlet he touches the the gym
on the back of the hand and when he does
the Silver Surfer is blasted with some
form of energy and what we also see is
that as a result of her actions with
restoring everything back to the way it
was before that the shrine of mistress
death is no longer there and so they're
more or less just standing on an
asteroid which presumably was what
Pharaohs had used to create the shrine
of mistress death and again nebula is
demonstrating the fact that she doesn't
know that Adam warlock was here in the
fact that she doesn't know that he's
left that he's no longer in the scene
anymore and so what she asks is how it
is that Doctor Strange and the Silver
Surfer are still there when presumably
they should have been destroyed and so
what what she recognizes here what she
more or less theorizes here is that this
presumably was due to the actions of
Doctor Strange this was due to the
actions of him intervening against her
will and so what she does is she
imprisons the hands of Doctor Strange to
keep him from being able to use his his
magic but what we see Thanos commenting
on here is telling nebula there was
another error in judgment that she had
yet again screwed up and that that it's
something that she has been fortunate
about so far that the errors in her
judgment haven't necessarily been major
but what she's about to learn is the
fact that when she set everything back
to 24 hours prior that she didn't fully
think it through and the reason why is
because 24 hours prior to the current
events that cosmic entities were not
imprisoned they were still free and
so what we see is that the cosmic
entities have now been released from
their binds and more or less what's
going to take place is an attempt by the
cosmic entities to destroy nebula but
what we see is that we transition back
to to the soul world to inside of the
soul Jim with Adam warlock and the
Silver Surfer and it appears as though
when the Silver Surfer was struck by
some form of energy from the gauntlet
that it may not necessarily have been a
killing blow from nebula more so than
Adam warlock entering the soul Jim and
pulling the Silver Surfer end with him
and what the Silver Surfer asks Adam
warlock here is why they're back in Soul
world why they're back inside of the the
soul Jim and what Adam warlock says here
is that his power is greatest within the
soul Jim that he is bound to the soul
Jim in ways that he's not fully
understanding of but that it's it's such
a bind that it allows him to utilize his
full potential now the reason for this
goes all the way back to the very
beginnings of Adam warlock when he was
given the soul Jim by the High
Evolutionary in an attempt to uh to take
back the counter-earth but that's of
course a story that we're not
necessarily gonna get into but what we
see Adam warlock saying here is I guess
explaining to the Silver Surfer what he
had previously explained to Thanos or
what we were already aware of that in
order for Adam warlock to successfully
bring an end to the Infinity Gauntlet
event that the Infinity Gauntlet had to
change hands that it had to leave Thanos
his hands and go into the hands of
somebody else now whether or not it was
going to be nebula or whether it had to
be somebody else's something that's not
explained to us and in this instance I
don't really think it really matters but
what Adam warlock says is that nebulous
confusion here the fact that she is
overwhelmed for the most part due to the
I guess sensory input of the of the
Infinity Gauntlet of all the the facets
of reality in addition to her
recognition of newfound power led her in
a place where it was very easy to take
advantage of that it was very easy to
use that to their advantage and so what
we see is that the Silver Surfer
realizes that Adam warlock and knew that
Thanos was going to lose the Infinity
Gauntlet that so the question is what
gonna do now what's going to take place
and Adam warlock simply says that he's
going to do what needs to be done and
that in order for this to succeed he's
going to need the Silver Surfer as a
spiritual anchor from here we transition
back to nebula and what we see is that
Galactus and Eon and the Celestials and
berry other various other cosmic beings
are using their power to attempt to
overpower nebula and again nebula is
able to use the Infinity Gauntlet even
if only on a base level and Thanos
explains this to us the analyst tells us
that even a a bumbling idiot for the
most part would be able to use the
extreme power of the Infinity Gauntlet
to override the power of the cosmic
entities just because of the fact that
even on a subconscious level they would
simply just not want to be defeated and
so the Infinity Gauntlet would exercise
that power accordingly but what we learn
is that again Thanos is commenting on
the fact that nebula using the infinite
power of the Infinity Gauntlet
is able to easily overpower the cosmic
entity she's able to defeat them readily
and what we see is that for the most
part the cosmic entities appear to be
entirely imprisoned they appear to be
cast into some form of stone and
completely locked up and what we also
see taking place here is that nebula is
more or less stating that her reign of
supremacy is just beginning that her
reign of omnipotence has just started
and that she's going to be effectively
taking over everything now what we see
is that she's telling Thanos that he is
going to be able to bear witness to a
new astral dynasty he's going to be able
to bear witness to the new reality that
she is creating and that there's going
to be a whole new era assured in with
regards to the earth-616 universe then
we see fan o saying let there be
something and Adam warlock says
disharmony and this is very interesting
here because what Adam warlock has done
here is he's more or less merged himself
with the soul Jim and by merging himself
with the soul Jim he has reached out to
the other five gems and when he reached
out to the other five infinity gems he
forced them to feedback on to nebula and
when this happened
the end
to Ghana became more than nebula could
bear and so nebula through the Infinity
Gauntlet down and so at this point
there's no one in possession of
absolutely power everybody has a base
set of abilities at this point we
learned what it was that dr. strange was
doing when he was using his powers and
what he had done is that when everything
was set back to normal that the
earthbound superheroes had all been
restored and they were sent back to
their previous forms and so he's called
in some of the more prominent members
some of the more powerful and strong
members of the earthbound superheroes
which of course include Eric Masterson
his Thor Drax the destroyer and the
Incredible Hulk
along with eros and he opens a portal to
allow them to enter but what we also see
here is that Thanos has broken free of
his bonds and for the most part this is
a very interesting set of circumstances
because what we're going to be seeing is
that while Doctor Strange uses his power
to attempt to confine the Infinity
Gauntlet that nebula knocks him off
guard and when she does the the bobble
or I guess the bubble that encloses the
Infinity Gauntlet goes away and so we
see in effect this mad dash for absolute
power we see everybody rushing to try to
gain this Infinity Gauntlet we see that
the Incredible Hulk is considering the
Infinity Gauntlet for himself eros is
trying to grab the gauntlet
danos is trying to grab the gauntlet and
Drax the destroyer is trying to beat up
the Incredible Hulk what we also see is
that amidst the conflict amidst the fray
that Adam warlock re-emerges from the
soul Jim and when he does he takes
possession of the Infinity Gauntlet and
he simply says let the conflict in and
what's really intriguing about this is
that this is one of the four most
pivotal panels or one of the four most
pivotal moments in Marvel Comics and is
one of the most recognized moments and
Marvel Comics simply because it heralds
the end of the Infinity Gauntlet event
and ushers and the story of warlock and
the Infinity watch but what we see as as
we continue here is that Adam warlock
begins to take on this mantle begins to
take on this role of trying to achieve
godhood as best he can of trying to more
or less be
I'm a perfect God in his eyes and he
says that he will deal with everything
that has taken place in his own fashion
and initially people are a little
skeptical here people are a little
unsure Fano says that the gauntlet
inherently belongs to him and Adam
warlock replies by saying that he would
simply lose it again because he doesn't
really desire it nebula says that the
path of the gauntlet belongs to her and
the question she asked Adam warlock is
what right does he have to power what
right does he have to the Infinity
Gauntlet and Adam warlock simply says
the Infinity Gauntlet is in his
possession and that that's right enough
and so what we see had a Morlock saying
is that his power with the Infinity
Gauntlet is a claim that they would also
they would all do well not to dispute
and that he is going to more or less set
everything to the way it's supposed to
be now what we'll see in Infinity
Gauntlet issue number six part two is we
will pick up with what all is going to
happen after Adam warlock gains the
Infinity Gauntlet what it is that he
does here and whether or not Adam
warlock will actually be able to
demonstrate himself as a true and fair
God or whether he will succumb to the
corruption that the Infinity Gauntlet
I guess involves with regards to people
who are wielding it with that being said
I'm gonna go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
peace
[Music]